syria's most vulnerable are suffering
and survival is traumatic despite all
the coaxing from the young cousin now
looking after her a mal won't talk the
five-year-old saw her whole family died
in a bombing she's hardly spoken since
no response from a mouth the doctors say
she'll recover from her own injuries but
the trauma will take much longer to get
over if ever we pray Bashar al-asad dies
she says and the same things happened to
his children
a shop owner gave us the CCTV it's
wednesday around half ten in sorrow
keepin it lib and they're taking cover
from their government warplanes this is
what civilians enid lib are up against
russian propaganda footage shows the
regime troops taking key towns amid lip
like Concha kun held by the rebels for
five years they've discovered tunnels
with weapons the regime justifies the
attacks saying it Lib is run by
terrorists there's also footage of
underground hospitals the regime claims
they're decoys to harbor fighters but
hospitals have been systematically
targeted by the regime this was Rama
Hospital a week ago this is how it looks
now that was the first hit he says the
second was there a third was in Seoul
there were four all together it was the
last functioning Hospital in South East
it would now reduced to rubble
this is an oxygen bottle he tells us is
oxygen a threat to Bashar al-assad
what does Putin found in Syrian that
justifies hitting hospitals this is to
help humans breathe we found much
evidence suggesting this was an
operating hospital with patients up
until the day of forming attacking
medical facilities is an international
war crime you can see this was all
operational the still medicines in in
the cupboards one of the few operating
hospitals in this area
the tactic is forcing tens of thousands
of civilians in this last rebel
territory in Syria to pack up and flee
towards the Turkish border the areas
controlled by groups deemed by Britain
and America to be extremists terror
outfits with a strict interpretation of
Islam and bound together only by hatred
of the Assad regime but there are
millions of civilians here too who are
moderates but have found themselves on
the same side after fleeing the regime
several times and are now on the move
again a lot of the village has emptied
over the past few days they're not
hanging around for anymore shelling or
bombing they're all now cornered indeed
Lib with little land to escape to but
still defiant we will stay here he says
we just want our families safe and our
furniture secure but we will stay
fighting and we'll hit them to finish
them off completely
those who can't or won't leave have
retreated underground women and small
children spend their days now cowering
in caves as they wait for information
about the attacks above life Enid Lib is
spent dodging the aircraft and spotter
drones used for launching attacks
the few functioning hospitals are filled
with the battered bodies of civilians
whilst the staff despair of the world's
indifferent I want to say people who do
this murder
there won't be peace until there is
justice in Syria but no one is listening
to Syria's cries Alex Crawford Sky News
ed Lib